Presently, Korea maintains a mandatory draft system...
...under which all able-bodied men over 20 must serve in the military for 24 to 27 months.
But this will change by 2020 ...
...as the Army intends to rely on volunteers for 80 percent of its new recruits...
... by phasing out mandatory conscription.
Currently, volunteers represent about 38 percent of the 570,000 strong ground forces.
Accordingly, the ratio of volunteer soldiers will be increased to 50 percent in 2010,...
...65 percent in 2015 and 80 percent in 2020.
The Army also plans to increase the number of non - commissioned officers (NCOs)...
...to some 40 percent by 2020,...
...offsetting the planned reduction of its enlisted soldiers under a 15 - year military reform package.
To maintain quality NCOs,...
...the Army is considering implementing a "salaried NCO employment plan",...
...under which enlisted soldiers who complete their service period...
...can serve longer in the military as NCOs for up to two more years.
Over the next 15 years,...
...the Army plans to build "smaller but stronger" units equipped with high-tech weapons systems.
The overall goal for all services is cutting 190,000 soldiers by 2020...
...to make a force of some 500,000 from the current 690,000.
Meanwhile,...
...the Army plans to more than double the number of female officers (currently 3.5% of all officers)...
...by 4,000 to 7,000 by 2020;...
...moreover, female officers will be able to serve in 16 of the 19 Army branches.